THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
ORDER.
WE WILL BE HEARING --
THE REMAINDER OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET TRAILER BILLS.
WE HAVE DISCUSSED THAT NEITHER
FROM FINANCE --
WHO CAN PERCENT OUR FIRST --
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR S. B..
EIGHT SIX TO THAT THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SO WE
WON'T BE CALLING ROLE AND WILL
BE TAKING THE PARENTS
[inaudible]
WISCONSIN AT THANK YOU.
CARLA CHO THING EVER DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE FIRST BILL SB
EIGHT SIXTY TWO MAKES A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT --
CENTER LAST HEARING THE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE A PROVISIONAL
UPDATE FOR CROSS REFERENCE.
AS WELL AS UPDATING CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY NINE FOUR RELATED
TRAILER BILLS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MITCHELL NOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM DO --
DOES THIS BILL AS AMENDED STILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES TO REQUEST A
POTENTIALLY UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLEVIATING
WAIT TIMES.
THE AMENDMENT SINCE LAST HEARING
ARE ONLY THE TWO THAT I I
MENTIONED OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEN ON ANY ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SIX TO OUR BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
OPPOSED TO S. B. IT'S SIX TO OUR
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR ON THEM.
OKAY SAYING NO WE'RE DON'T MOVE
ON TO SB.
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR WHICH IS OUR
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL.
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
MISS ABOUT PREFERRED BEING.
IF YOU GO OVER TO BEGIN --
GIVE YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BELL FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE --
THIS IS FOR S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR AMENDMENT SINCE LAST TIME
--
THE BILL IS BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE ALLOW THE DISTRICTS
WITHOUT STEM IMMERSE YOU PORTS
MELONES USE PROCEEDS FROM THOSE
--
LOANS FOR SURPLUS PROPERTY SALES
OR LEASE.
PAYMENTS FOR DEBT SERVICE AND
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS.
ALSO PERHAPS DISTRICTS IN THIS
OUTSTANDING EMERGENCY PERSONAL
LOANS THAT SELL THE PROPERTY
LEAST.
SURPLUS PROPERTY FROM
ELIGIBILITY FOR FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS NOT --
NOT PROPERTY HARDSHIPS AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IN SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAMS.
YEP UNANSWERED QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THEY TAKE YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
NOTHING ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IS
SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR OKAY WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO SP EIGHT
FOUR SIX WHICH IS OUR EMPLOYMENT
--
TRAILER.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FEEL FREE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
PHOTO SEND APARTMENT FINANCE.
I'M SB FORTY SIX IS THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAILER BILL.
ON THE SCHOOLS DISCUSS AT THE
AUGUST FIFTEENTH HEARING IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON THEM SINCE THAT
TIME INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
THE CONTROLLER.
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
OR AGAINST ASIANS ARE NOT LIABLE
TO RETURN.
OUR REFUND FISHER DUES DEDUCTED
IF THEY'RE PERMITTED AT THE TIME
IN PAID PRIOR TO JUNE.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I'M
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THINK IT WAS FROM.
NO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
WHAT REASON WAS THIS LAST
AMENDMENT --
INCORPORATED IT INTO THE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL THAT'S
ARE THE EMPLOYMENT TRAILER BILL.
THIS WAS INCLUDED TO BASICALLY
I'M PROVIDED CLARIFICATION THAT.
ON PRIOR TO JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH
AND THE DECISION THAT IN THIS
CASE THAT THOSE FAIR SHARED USE
THAT WERE DEDUCTED --
WERE DIE IN THAT WERE PERMITTED
AT THE ALLOWABLE UNDER.
AND WHY DO YOU FEEL THAT THIS
CLARIFICATION SHOULD BE MADE
RATHER THAN ABIDING BY THE
RULING OF THE COURT.
AND REALLY --
AS FAR AS THIS IS CONCERNED I'M
A REALLY IS CLARIFYING EXISTING
LAW -- WE
BELIEVE THAT --
BY MAKING THIS CHANGE IT --
BASICALLY CLARIFIES THE INTENT
THAT IT EXISTED PRIOR TO THAT
DECISION.
OKAY BUT I DON'T I'M NOT GOING
TO BE A JOKE ABOUT IT BUT I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH YOU.
AND OTHER COURT ACTUALLY DIDN'T
RULE ON WHETHER OR NOT
[inaudible]
THE IT'S RULING COULD BE APPLIED
RETROACTIVELY AND I'M SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE SEEING SOME
KIND OF FEDERAL.
PRESIDENT SAID IN ESTABLISHING
THAT SO I I DON'T THINK THAT WE
HAVE ANY BUSINESS.
ESTABLISHED ATTEMPTING TO
ESTABLISH THAT AT THE STATE
LEVEL I DON'T THINK THAT
ANYTHING THAT WE DO HERE IS
GOING TO STAND.
OUT IN PARTICULARLY I DON'T FEEL
LIKE THIS HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE BUDGET SO --
THAT'S ANOTHER OBJECTION I HAVE
AS TO WHY IT'S BEING INCLUDED A
TRAILER BILL COULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT IN TERMS
OF THE ABILITY OF THE CONTROLLER
TO MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS AND?
IT WOULD POTENTIALLY LIMIT
FUTURE LIABILITY ON THIS WOULD
APPLY TO ANY KEEP APPENDING OR
FUTURE CLAIMS.
I WHICH WOULD.
TIE BACK TO POTENTIAL YET COSTS
FOR THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
OKAY THAT THAT'S TENUOUS TO ME
THAT THAT'S THE JUSTIFICATION WE
ALWAYS USED TO TIE SOMETHING
THAT'S POLICY INTO THE BUDGET.
SO ARE AN UNFORTUNATE I WAS
LOOKING FOR VOTING FOR THIS
UNFORTUNATE NOW BECAUSE OF THIS
AMENDMENT.
I WOULD HAVE TO OPPOSE IT BUT
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
I THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
I ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT FOUR SIX MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC UP OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT FOUR SIX OKAY SEEN NUMBER
GONNA MOVE FORWARD TO S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN THREE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF THEM ARE USED TO
DISCUSS.
BUT THAT PLEASE BEGIN.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
RATIFIES THE CONTRACTS BETWEEN
THE STATE AND BARGAINING UNIT
NINE THE ENGINEERS AND
BARGAINING UNITS AND SCIENTISTS.
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO
NOT TAKEN.
DO NOT TAKE EFFECT UNLESS OF
FUNDS ARE SPECIFICALLY
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
OF THE BILL APPROPRIATES HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
SIX POINT TWO MILLION WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE CAREER
COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH BOTH
CONTRACTS.
OF INCREASE OR THE AGREEMENT
WITH PEG I'M IMPACTS
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
NICK WHO THE GENERAL SALARY
INCREASE OF FOUR POINT JULY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND 4%
BEGINNING JULY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN OF THE AGREEMENT
WITH GUARDIAN TEN IMPACTS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
AND INCLUDES THE GENERAL SALARY
INCREASE OF 5% BEGINNING.
JULY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN IN
ANOTHER 5% INCREASE BEGINNING
JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY WITHOUT I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEES
MISTER WOULDN'T.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FEELS
THAT THESE.
MEMORANDUMS ARE FISCALLY
PRUDENT.
SO -- I'LL
TAKE ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
CONCERN ME SO THE DEMO YOU WITH
BARGAINING UNIT.
NINE HAS A GENERAL SORRY OF
INCREASE OF FOUR POINT 5% THE
FIRST YEAR 4% THE SECOND YEAR --
BARDEEN ATTEND THE INCREASES ARE
5% 5% AND IN ADDITION TO THOSE
GENERAL SALARY INCREASES THERE'S
A NUMBER OF INCREASES FOR PAY
DIFFERENTIALS ALLOWANCES
RETENTION BONUSES THINGS LIKE
THAT SO.
IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL.
THE INCREASE FOR BOTH THOSE
BARGAINING UNITS AND I WAS
LOOKING ON YOUR WEBSITE LAST
NIGHT. TO SEE IF I'D MISSED
SOMETHING AND I WAS LOOKING AT
THE TO PUT DEAL LAUGHS ESTIMATE
FOR THE INFLATION RATE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH ALTHOUGH IT'S
BEEN TAKING UP RECENTLY IS STILL
WELL UNDER 4%.
SO I'M WONDERING HOW YOU FEEL
LIKE THESE.
THESE INCREASES ARE JUSTIFIED
BECAUSE IT'S ALARMING TO ME I
MEAN CLEARLY IF WE I CONTINUALLY
TO IT TO CONTINUE TO GRANT
SALARY INCREASES.
IN EXCESS OF THE RATE OF
INFLATION TO OUR EMPLOYEES --
WE WOULD RUN OUT OF MONEY VERY
QUICKLY STE IT'S CLEARLY NOT A
SUSTAINABLE ACTION FOR YOU TO
TAKE SO HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY THOSE
LEVELS OF INCREASE FOR THOSE TWO
BARGAINING UNITS.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THAT IS
THAT -- YOU
THESE ARE BOTH AGREEMENTS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE STATE.
NAM AND THE UNION ON THESE
CONTRACTS ARE YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT THEY DO INCLUDE OTHER
PROVISIONS OUTSIDE OF JUST THE
STANDARD GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES.
I WE BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE FAIR
DEALS ON GIVEN SALARY SURVEYS
THAT WERE DONE.
TO ESSENTIALLY KEEP THE STATE
ONLINE WITH.
AS WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
SO I'M KIND OF LOOKING AT THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THESE DEALS
FOR EXAMPLE OF THE PAID
CONTRACT.
ON THE TWO YEAR BUDGETARY COSTS
ON THIS TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION HOW
MAY POINT FOUR MILLION WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND.
THE CONTRACT WITH THE SCIENTISTS
THAT IS A THREE YEAR THERE HAS A
THREE YEAR BUDGETARY COSTS OF
ABOUT SIXTY THREE AND A HALF
MILLION.
OF WHICH TWELVE POINT ONE
MILLION IS GENERAL FUND --
BUT JUST TO REITERATE ME OF
THESE ARE SUBJECT TO THE
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE STATE.
TOM AND THE UNIONS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE FAIR
DEALS ON PRESENTED BEFORE YOU.
OKAY SO AMEND THE QUESTION WAS.
HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY?
WHY THAT THOSE ARE FAIR GIVEN
THE FACT THAT INFLATION IS
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS?
AND THIS IS A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN THE ANSWER YOU GAVE
ME WAS WELL THAT'S WHAT WE
NEGOTIATED WHICH IS NOT WHAT I
WAS ASKING WAS ASKING.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT BEING A
FAIR DEAL.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT SOME IN
ADDITION TO BEING SUBJECT TO
NEGOTIATIONS HOW WE DO LOOK AT
SELLERS SERVICE EVER DONE TO
HOPEFULLY.
ON KEEP THE STATE SALARIES IN
LINE WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN
THEIR PEERS COME IN.
YOU KNOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS
WELL AS THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
OKAY I DONE UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T FIND THAT ANSWER
SATISFACTORY BUT NORMALLY I IN
AND YOU KNOW THIS COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT I'VE
SUPPORTED THEM OR USE THAT.
WE'VE HAD WITH OTHER BARGAINING
UNITS WHEN I THINK THAT THERE
FISCALLY PRUDENT IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE STATE I
CERTAINLY AM INTERESTED IN
COMPENSATING.
ALL OF OUR STATE EMPLOYEES
FAIRLY BRITISH JUST DOESN'T
DOESN'T SEEM PRUDENT TO APPROVE
THIS LEVEL FISCAL INCREASE.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT I THINK
YOUR POINT ABOUT INFLATION'S
VERY THERE WILL TAKE AND I WOULD
SAY I KNOW THAT.
THE BAY AREA WE HAVE VERY MUCH
RECRUITING AND RETAINING STATE
EMPLOYEES.
SIMPLY BECAUSE FRANKLY ALTHOUGH
I COUNTIES IN MANY OF THE CITY'S
ACTUALLY PAY MORE SO THAT
OBVIOUSLY I WOULD HOPE THAT THAT
WOULD BE IN ONE OF THE FACTORS
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WAS
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
CHURCH AT NIGHT COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT MISTER CHAIR AND
I'VE DEALT WITH THIS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AS WELL --
HOWEVER LAWMAKER POINT THAT YOU
NEVER CAN ASSUME THAT PAY
DIFFERENTIAL IS THE REASON WHY
YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE OF
RETAINING EMPLOYEES.
AND IF YOU SUSPECT THAT THAT'S
THE CASE THEN WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO IS TO DO A STUDY IN WHICH TO
YOU INTERVIEW DON'T EXERT OUR
VIEW WITH EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
LEAVING.
AND TRY AND FIGURE OUT WHY
THEY'RE LEAVING AND WHAT YOU
FIND OUT IS IS DISPLAY A WIDE
VARIETY OF REASONS AND OF THAT
AT THAT.
CAN SUGGEST CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
FOR THE STATE BUT YOU CERTAINLY
NEED TO GO THROUGH THAT STEP
BEFORE YOU RUSH TO GRANTING.
A AND M. O. U. S. SALARY
INCREASES THAT ARE WELL IN
EXCESS OF INFLATION --
YEAH AND THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL.
FAIR ENOUGH I BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS MY COMMITTEE.
UP WITH THAT OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
IS SUPPORT.
MONTH S. B. --
EIGHT SEVEN THREE MISTER
CHAIRMAN GOOD EVENING I AM A TWO
FOR TONIGHT TO TOP AND FOR UNIT
NINE AND UNIT.
TEN IN SUPPORT OF THESE
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
AGREEMENTS --
TO YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE I'D SAY
THAT INFLATION.
IS NOT THE FACTOR THAT IS MOST
IMPORTANT HERE BUT THE
COMPETITIVENESS OF THE JOB
MARKET FOR ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS.
THIS IS A FULL EMPLOYMENT.
ECONOMY WHERE SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS HAVE VERY VERY VERY
VERY MANY OP [inaudible]
AND THIS AGREEMENT BOTH THE
PAGAN THE CAPS AGREEMENT.
KEEPS THEM COMPETITIVE WITH
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COUNTERPARTS [inaudible]
AND NOT.
PRIVATE SECTOR OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY HAVE. TO ALSO TAKE --
SO THIS IS WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER BOTH FAIR AND
REASONABLE AGREEMENTS.
WE WOULD URGE ANOTHER.
THANK YOU NEITHER PRIOR COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF ANY [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
IN OPPOSITION TURNER BE
[inaudible]
EIGHT SEVEN THREE OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS REMOVED
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN WHICH IS
OUR GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRIBAL.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN IS THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
ON THIS WAS ALSO DISCUSSED AT
THE AUGUST FIFTEENTH HEARING BY
THIS COMMITTEE.
MEMBER SINCE THAT TIME OUR
TECHNICAL IN NATURE EQUAL
APPLICATION OF ITS PROVISIONS
STALL WARNING BODIES.
OF FOR EMERGENCY PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS.
THANK IN THIS MOMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SO.
WE HAD A GREAT DEAL OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL LAST
WEEK I'M AND I DID OFFER SOME
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL
[inaudible] EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN
TO SUPPLEMENTS ARE I GUESS
COMPLEMENT THE AUDIT PROPOSAL BY
MY COLLEAGUE.
AND SAID WE COULD SEE WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN AT THE DMV.
AND SPECIFICALLY THE AUDIT WOULD
HAVE DETERMINE THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIMES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH AND
WITHOUT APPOINTMENTS.
I WOULD HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
STEPS DMB HAS TAKEN TO REDUCE
WAIT TIMES IN INCREASE
APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY BUT
ALSO DETERMINE WHETHER WAIT
TIMES HAVE INCREASED SINCE THE
DMB BEGAN OFFERING.
REAL ID DRIVER'S LICENSES ID
CARDS.
WHAT ALSO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
DME IS ON TRACK TO MEET A TIRING
EXPECTATIONS AND WHETHER
EMPLOYEES ARE ADEQUATELY TRAINED
AMONG OTHER THINGS?
AUGUST EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE REJECTED MY
COLLEAGUES PER REQUEST FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT OF THE DIEM
THE TO INVESTIGATE.
THE WAIT TIME CRISIS AND ON THAT
SAME DAY.
THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BODY CAM BUDGET
COMMITTEE APPROVED. SIXTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION AND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES --
AT WHICH IN MY MIND IS GIVING
THE DMB A BLANK CHECK WITHOUT
ANY RESTRICTIONS OR STRINGS AND
I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS.
IN THIS ROOM AND EVEN THOSE WHO
ARE AT THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE HAVE A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
AT THE DMV AND I DON'T.
I JUST WANT EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
I DON'T BLAME.
DMB EMPLOYEES I DON'T THINK THEY
CREATED THE PROBLEM I THINK
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE TO CREATE
THOSE PROBLEMS --
I KNOW THE DMB EMPLOYEES THAT
I'VE SPOKEN WITH IN FACT THE ONE
I WOMAN WE SPOKE WITH.
WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS GETTING HER
TO PERMIT HER DRIVER'S LICENSE
SHE SAID?
SHE USED TO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT
ABOUT --
COMPLETE ABOUT.
FOURTY TRANSACTIONS A DAY BUT
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGE THAT
REMAIN SHE'S NOW DOWN THE TWENTY
FIVE SO I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
MISUNDERSTAND THAT SOMEHOW I
THINK DMB EMPLOYEES ARE
SABOTAGING THE PUBLIC I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE CASE.
I JUST THINK THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW.
WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE NOR DO WE
SO HOW CAN WE POSSIBLY EXPECT
THEM TO FIX IT?
AND JUST GIVING THEM MORE MONEY
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM BECAUSE THAT
MONEY ISN'T THE ISSUE I THINK
IT'S THE PROCESS --
SO AN AUDIT WOULD HAVE TOLD US
EXACTLY WHERE THE PROBLEM IS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND WE DIDN'T GET THAT AUDIT I'M
DISAPPOINTED BUT I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF WE CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THAT THE CHAIR HAS ALLOWED ME TO
ACT -- TO
EXPRESS --
NOT ONLY MY FRUSTRATION I THINK
FRUSTRATION OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES OF ALLEN THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S MORE THAN
PRETTY SET UP FRUSTRATION ISLAM
SPREAD THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ABSOLUTELY [inaudible]
ON KIND OF DEPARTMENT FINANCES
ANY COMMENT ON THAT OR NOT.
NUMBER PONDERED PUBLIC FINANCING
DIDN'T QUITE YOUR QUESTION THEIR
OWN.
BUT YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THAT A
CONTINUES TO BE A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND THEY'RE
TAKING THEM ON YOU KNOW A NUMBER
OF MEASURES --
THAT ARE BRINGING DOWN WAIT
TIMES -- I
THINK -- MC
17% OF THE STATEWIDE AND AND AND
THE BUSIER OFFICES HIGHS OF
BRICK BRING HIM DOWN BY. 27% SO
--
THEN ANOTHER MAKING A LOT OF
EFFORT THAT THANK YOU --
WITH THAT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NOT SING IN THE AND I SEE ANY
OTHER FURTHER COME ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OPPOSED S.
B. [inaudible]
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN OKAY.
NOT WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
OUR HEARING.
BUDGET COMMITTEE JERKED